here's an interesting follow-up on a
story from earlier this year back in
january we covered this guy named
christopher key who was promoting the
drinking of urine in order to treat or
prevent covid
and we talked about it at the time and i
explained to you then that a lot of this
coveted quack stuff
it's a recycling of old ideas that have
been going around for a long time urine
has been promoted in the past for
treating cancer even though the cancer
society says there's no evidence at all
for therapeutic use of urine
they've talked about using urine to
irrigate the sinuses almost like a pea
neti pot for brushing teeth applying it
directly to the skin as a skin treatment
of some kind and the origins or the
oranges of this urine therapy thing
is the idea
that certain tumor proteins are present
in the urine of cancer patients and the
idea is
if you introduce urine into the
digestive tract by drinking it
the erroneous belief is your body will
make antibodies against the tumor
proteins and it'll destroy the cancer
that's like one example now there's no
evidence of that whatsoever it's true
that urine can contain tumor antigens
there's no evidence that drinking it
massaging with it bathing with it
cooking with it or any other urine
application is going to stimulate
antibody production in any way fight
cancer treat any symptom or disease
so that was the idea before from
christopher key was the drinking of
urine he's now moved on to promoting
injecting urine here is a clip of him
uh
at least claiming that he's injecting
himself with aged urine you know how
sometimes people will age stakes this is
aged urine i'm doing intramuscular um i
have your iodine but i'm just going to
sterilize it with my own urine right um
and
and whatnot but talk about the stem
cells
right all right so this stuff and as
this is going on you see him take out a
syringe um
pretty much every every type of stem
cell is available in your urine so stem
cells are the base
pure dna
cell that will start replicating yeah um
additional cells for regeneration and
repair i mean everybody's hearing about
regeneration
um repair people are flying to thailand
to get stem cell injections done over
there yeah so the idea there is that
christopher key has injected himself
with uh urine
and
some people wrote to me saying david he
clearly isn't really injecting himself i
don't think it matters because if people
believe it it's dangerous and this is
all from the same school of thought uh
that sometimes includes homeopathy
sometimes it includes you know some of
these other yeah i'm not gonna wrap too
much uh this is what it is okay now this
is extraordinarily dangerous if you you
know the christopher key said he's
injecting the urine intramuscularly
if you inject urine into a vein
it can get very bad very quickly there's
actually a study called lethal sepsis
and multi-organ failure
after accidental injection of urine in a
drug addict and the story is about a 33
year old drug addict that
injected
uh
urine
because he kept it in the fridge in case
he needed it for a drug screening and
then he thought it was methadone and
injected it and it went into a vein and
uh was confused and shivering and had
all sorts of different symptoms sepsis
it was crazy okay so this is all
extraordinarily dangerous and they just
don't seem to be stopping now i
genuinely wonder like are they really
making money with this i don't know the
guy who's interviewing christopher key
here is dr edward group and he runs some
kind of natural healing thing
and um
does he make money promoting urine
therapy i just don't know i don't i
don't know exactly like what the what
the the money piece is now as i've said
before
there is one possible legitimate
life-saving use of urine
and it is as follows if you are
completely dehydrated you're without
water you're on the verge of dying
there is a short period during which
drinking your own urine could
extend your life just enough
to be rescued or to get to water right
urine is 95 water
and
it's believed that drinking your own
urine might allow you to survive an
extra day or two it is strictly speaking
safe it replenishes some lost water but
the problem is the other five percent of
urine that's not water
is not something you want a lot of in
your body right you're taking the stuff
that your kidneys have filtered out and
you're putting it back in and putting it
back into your kidneys and this can
cause really bad symptoms and long long
term problems but if there's anything
that in the urine therapy world would we
would say is sort of legit
it would be you might extend a deadly
situation with no water by a day or two
and that's basically it absolutely
horrifying stuff